si on dit que le chien est le meilleur
ami de l'homme il ne semble pas en être
de même pour nos amis les people des
stars sur les réseaux sociaux semblent
parfois plus bête que les bêtes
exemple avec booba qui s'est fait
épingler il ya peu par l'association 30
millions d'amis
après avoir posté la photo d'un lionceau
au volant d'une voiture un cliché qui
n'a pas du tout fait rire l'association
qui lui a fait savoir sur les réseaux
bonjour booba je préfère sauver les
animaux mais pas en repos ce temps sur
instagram la photo d'un lion soit en
voiture
une référence à une chanson dans
laquelle il déclarait et en fondant sur
nos merdes
perso j'ai descendu
même chose pour justin bieber dont le
caprice n'a pas fait rire l'association
peta le jeune chanteur s'est en effet
procuré pour la modique somme de 32
mille dollars 2 ch à savannah baptisé
ton et sushi d'une race hybride dont
l'élevage est extrêmement limité aux
états unis un achat qui n'a pas plu du
tout justin bieber pour inspirer ses
fans partout dans le monde à sauver une
vie en adoptant un chat dans un refuge
local plutôt que de contribuer à la
crise de la surpopulation animale en
2018 karim benzema a lui aussi subi les
foudres des internautes après avoir
posté une photo de lui avec un bébé
tigre un cliché que tout le monde
n'avait pas trouvé trop mignon comme la
dirigeante d'entreprise laurence parisot
cha benzema pouvez vous nous expliquer
d'où vient ce bébé tigre où est sa maman
que comptez vous en faire ne pensez vous
pas qu'il serait plus heureux dans son
milieu naturel
mais preuve qu'on peut être doux et à
taper dans une balle et sur un clavier
karim benzema lui avait répondu avec
efficacité
dernier exemple dwayne johnson alias the
rock en visite dans un parc aquatique le
comédien avait pris des photos avec des
animaux détenu en captivité est exploité
comme sur ce cliché où il fait un bras
de fer avec une baleine blanche pour
info la baleine est à droite
voilà beaucoup de choses choquantes dans
le sujet évidemment être qu'on n'en fait
pas trop
autour du sujet sur les les animaux ça
devient un sujet tellement sensible je
fais une parenté de 30 secondes quand je
parle de la corrida marque parler des
cultures jeu comparer les cultures des
pays en disant qu'on n'a pas de leçon à
donner par rapport à notre notre culture
ou à par rapport aux cultures des autres
pays ça a été pris comme mathieu défend
les taureaux qui me enfin la télé
souvent caricaturale c'est hallucinant
j'ai même pas osé répondre à certains
saints b s'il qui m'avait insulté ce
serait leur donner trop de valeur
donc voilà c'est la question qu'on s'est
posée ce qu'on ne fait pas un peu trop
autour des animaux aujourd'hui il ya
tous les bouts de ce côté tous les noms
de ce côté ça pouvait pas s'inventer oui
mathieu alterman pourquoi on en fait
trop alors je suis évidemment ans pour
qu'on soigne les animaux qu'on leur
fasse pas de mal évidemment on est tous
comme ça autour de la table mais il ya
un moment il ya un nouveau mouvement qui
s'appelle les antispécistes vous savez
ces gens qui considèrent qu'un moustique
c'est pareil que nous finalement on vous
dit que vous avez tous un moustique
l'été vous fait insulter sur les réseaux
sociaux bien sûr on vous dit que vous
avez tué une araignée que vous avez peur
en route voilà et sa honda les ex oui
mais ils sont plus en plus d'importance
et d'extrémistes sont maintenant plus de
bruit et aujourd'hui les gens montrent
des poulets qu'on est en train de tuer
et disent que c'est pareil que la shoah
mais moi ça me gêne de voir non maraissa
d'accord
les amis j'ai lu ça aussi ça la haskala
c'est n'importe quoi et c'est
effectivement vous avez fait un
parallèle avec certaines causes
notamment chez les féministes évidemment
je suis pour les familles il ya pas prêt
mais il ya des moments où les
extrémistes ont beaucoup plus de bruit
que les modérés notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux
et ça nuit à la cause au final seulement
j'ai même entendu aujourd'hui sur une
épave également été assassin ce qui
devient hallucinant et qu'effectivement
on n'avait pas un appartement au moins
200 m² à paris on ne pouvait pas avoir
un chien ça devient un petit pas mais
parce qu'on écoute importe qui et
n'importe quel idiot qui dit kane
d'auzat pardon c'est souvent ceux qui
ont la parole la preuve la donne alors
non guillaume
alors non virtuel vous pardonne presque
deux minutes on n'en fait pas trop tôt
de suse non je crois pas c'est quand on
est en train de déconner à l'âge de
pierre de la conscience animale et en 1
35 ans compte que les animaux sont
capables d'empathie d'intelligence on
s'en rend compte que maintenant on sait
je constate que c'est comme ça et oui
moi je suis choqué quand booba mais un
lionceau sur une voiture alors chuté de
pas très grave vers et luc wiseman a
lyon c'est gravissime et jetez vos
lâchetés des animaux et le trafic
d'animaux sauvages est en train
d'exploser donc si c'est grave de faire
ce genre de choses parce que ça veut
dire que c'est mignon peut avoir un
petit lionceau on retrouve de plus en
plus d'animaux sauvages chez des
particuliers non il ne faut pas c'est
dangereux alors je suis désolé c'est
d'avancer plus rapidement quand rachel
brancher un micro ondes quand on est
connu quand on est suivie sur les
réseaux sociaux etc
je pense que c'est notre devoir sauver
willy s'est sauvé guillaume de voir de
quoi non mais c'est c'est leur devoir de
montrer l'exemple en fête avec tout ce
qu'on entend on entend beaucoup encore
des des animaux qui sont torturés qui
est tombé mais c'est pas la question on
est tous d'accord connaît tous les
problèmes là tu me fais un peu time is
on est tous contre les animaux qui
souffrent on est tous contre la
souffrance et la guerre mais non pas sur
la question c'est est ce qu'on n'en fait
pas trop mais voilà pas du tout mes
matches on voit ça de nombreux aux gens
envie de perdre on s'est quand même pas
super facile championne d'europe de
l'abandon alors sébastien et luc non
mais on peut peut-être faire la
différence entre les antispécistes et
des gens comme brigitte bardot qui
défendent des animaux on a laissé pas
aymeric caron non plus et là on remarque
que c'est souvent des rappeurs des
footballeurs enfin des décérébrés qui
est qu'il offre
mais c'est vrai qu'ils exhibent des
animaux comme joey starr qui tapait sur
un singe à huy a été condamné donc voilà
on peut pas dire que ces gens là donnent
le bon exemple et c'est pas extrémiste
de la rural en revenant sébastien des
taxes de plus de plus de plus quand
aujourd'hui on amène un animal sur un
plateau je rappelle que chez dechavanne
à l'époque donc c'est nous tout le monde
le faisait même sur ces 8 à l'époque
même mois gpu ouf
et encore trois quatre années ça
choquait personne aujourd'hui pas chômé
un animal sur un plateau mouloud l'a
fait sur canal+ il s'excuse et les
larmes aux yeux ça devient aberrant
alors si vous voulez c'est une espèce de
ligues de vertu maintenant voilà on a
maintenant lieu au boulot du lait
d'huile a dû s'expliquer dire excusez
moi s'est avéré ne soit tout le monde
m'attendait les footeux lui comme ça
qu'on terrain là j'ai fait venir à lyon
sur le plateau qu'est ce que ça fait moi
je lui en saut et sûrement un élevage
déjà qu'il est sur un plateau ou pas tu
veux pas lui faire plus de mal
on a tous été au cirque quand on était
petits on a tous été donnée ménagerie
alors dans la conscience animale c'est
super d'être à la fois que j'étais au
marché aux fleurs ya une semaine elle
passe externe l on chiale boyer était
hyper pénible et puis elle dit non mais
c'est un être humain comme tout le monde
j'ai celle existante est pas l être
humain justement tu as l'animal après
queen ne détrônera est au dessus de
l'animal et les gens mélangent design en
est tous pages ça on est tous pareils on
a tous de la même conscience les pauvres
ils sont tristes il faut à un rythme
mois je suis en train de faire un
documentaire sur le sur le salon
d'agriculture et de servir une cure m'a
dit s'il te plaît guillaume si tu fais
le situe film sur le cervin agriculture
tu ne pourras pas filmer aucune
coulisses parce qu'on ne veut pas
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça à l'air du
temps et comme ça on ne veut pas voir
des cent vallées h
dugas mieux en camion pour venir dans le
salon parce que le paysan peut
éventuellement lui donner les données un
pic way et une aux rapports arriver ça
tu n'auras pas de filmer la nuit parce
que parfois y ait du bruit des animaux
sont stressés et on ne montrera plus
exactement il s'entraîne d'ajustement
que ils votent pu montrer la réalité la
réalité c'est quand il sort une vache
bas d'un camion benne il faut les pick
and go away poussé pour qu'elle avance
et ça situe le film ils vont se faire
insulter les piles dans mes dents gens
si vous la rentrée avec les miens de
l'extrême c'est que sur montre ça on va
se faire insulter ça devient aberrant
que c'est en ça que ça devient aberrant
un dernier mot 4 et jean claude van se
trompent de combat spector a raison
focus eu quelques animaux exhibé en
public sur des bâches
concernant les ruptures on se trompe de
combat le vrai danger pause animaux
c'est la déforestation c'est les
pesticides qui les tue c'est tout lassus
et là on vous oublie pas là dessus et au
focus là dessus pour détourner le regard
des vrais problèmes sans exception
animalia 40%
vous a posé la question de twitter
pardon ajoute un petit peu après par de
trop oui à 60 pourtant c'était fascinant
mais les gens pensent qu'un homme comme
nous aujourd'hui ça devient aberrant
avec une fois encore il faut ramener le
débat au centre ça devient aberrant et
qu'on te parle un seul sujet les
insultes qu'on peut se prendre et amitié
à rémi gaillard c'est quand même
hallucinant
voilà revenus à un petit peu sur terre